the number one reason I push patients is
because patients will give you the air
cover to take risk if you realize how I
mean do you know what I wish for all of
you 25 year olds in here that you know
how young you feel at 40 because 40s
[ __ ] old to you I was just there and
the news alert they're gonna kind of
feel exactly the same and when you
understand that and then once you go
insular one of the reasons maybe I've
never had a mentor is because I don't
value anybody else's opinion more than
my own and that's a very it's it's it's
a and I'll tell you why that's important
because if I lose then I deserve it big
ascent if I win I deserve it but the way
to really eliminate fear is by not
giving a [ __ ] about anybody's opinion my
losses are mine I'll deal with that
myself
I don't need your two cents you're
losing plenty on your own
that
patience an inner voice makes you
unbeatable it's crazy how I feel my
whole life never had peer pressure never
did anything anything ever ever that I
didn't want to do because just didn't
value somebody else's opinion over mine
and that comes from good parenting
circumstance DNA a million [ __ ]
things I don't know how to teach that
what I'm just trying to do is I'm trying
to become in a weird way I like being
popular because I become your courage I
think the most flattering thing that's
happening to me in my life is I'm
becoming people's courage because when
they take risk and they take ridicule
they point to me
and then I tell their parents to go [ __ ]
themselves and it's a very very very
interesting if you look be like I don't
know how deep any of you are in my
content I know you are just like that is
what I'm doing that is what I'm doing
and it's a very good feeling I feel very
happy because I think I'm bringing
people value because let me tell you
what's way more scary than failure
regret you just don't know it yet
regret is [ __ ] poison
and you start feeling it when you can't
do anything about it I have a funny
feeling when you're 65 you don't feel
that much different than 40 you don't
feel that much different 25 problem is
you're starting to either
got it
but I agree with you the relationship
with parenting and the conservative
nature of the culture leads to a lot of
that which is too bad because you think
you're doing your parents a favor by
appeasing them but later in life you're
gonna really be mad at them and resent
them and it's not gonna play out
[Music]